[Musica]
Buonasera
Vi siete mai chiesti Perché quando si
osservano le stelle cadenti che poi
sappiamo benissimo non essere stelle
cadenti ma piccoli meteoriti che solcano
il cielo si esprime un desiderio Ecco
Fin dall'antichità si riteneva che il
destino degli uomini fosse legato alle
stelle e quindi che la caduta di una
stella la mancanza di una stella desse
luogo all'opportunità del fatto che il
destino non era più scritto in qualche
modo l'uomo poteva a quel punto veder
cambiato il proprio futuro per questo
motivo chi vede una stella cadente a
quel punto può esprimere un desiderio un
desiderio di cambiamento del proprio
futuro e quindi di realizzazione di un
sogno
un'usanza quest'ultima Certamente molto
antica che ci fa anche risalire al fatto
che la parola desiderio viene dal latino
desiderio che significa proprio mancanza
di stelle Ecco le stelle cadenti o i
piccoli meteoriti ci introducono proprio
all'argomento di questo Talk
qualcuno di voi potrebbe aver già visto
immagini come quelle che sto mostrando
in questa in questo video sicuramente
terrificanti assolutamente sconvolgenti
dal punto di vista della potenza visiva
queste fanno parte di un film girato nel
1998 che va sotto il nome di di impact
ma ci chiediamo è possibile che un
evento come questo si possa realizzare
anche sulla terra
Ecco Guardate queste immagini riprese da
una Dash cam di un'automobile il 15
febbraio del 2013 riprendono un
asteroide che cade e investe una parte
di questa zona degli Urali del Sud
vicino a una piccola cittadina chiamata
celiabinsk Ecco questo evento ha
liberato una energia tale
di circa 30 volte la bomba di Hiroshima
e questo polite il cosiddetto bolide di
celiabinsk si pensa che fosse una massa
di circa 10.000 tonnellate e che è
esplosa Fra 30 e 50 km dal suolo
ha rovinato distrutto circa 200.000
metri quadri di finestre facendo danni e
anche feriti per circa 1000 persone
Allora quello che vedete in questa
immagine è il famoso Meteor kratter
negli Stati Uniti un diametro di circa
un chilometro e due è una profondità di
circa 200 metri si pensa che questo
oggetto possa essere stato creato da un
meteorite un piccolo oggetto di circa 30
metri di diametro che possa essere
esploso circa 65.000 anni fa e in questo
caso si pensa che la energia rilasciata
da questo evento fosse dell'ordine di
circa 133 volte L'energia della bomba di
Hiroshima
esattamente come Il Meteor Crater
l'intero globo è coperto di cicatrici
così le potremmo chiamare di impatti che
si sono svolti Ovviamente nella storia
della terra Vedete qui tutta una serie
di Tracce di impatti di meteoriti che si
sono verificati in qualche milione di
anni che danno luogo a diametri di
crateri che vanno fra circa 4 e circa
240 km
Ma allora mi chiediamo ci chiediamo
proteggersi dai Near Heart of dayneo
così vengono chiamati è solo una
questione di supereroe anche qui facendo
uso di immagini di film
Fortunatamente no sia la NASA che Lesa
rispettivamente le agenzie spaziali
degli Stati Uniti e dell'Europa stanno
lavorando fino al 2011 a questo progetto
congiunto che va sotto il nome di Aida
asteroid impact and deflection
Assessment Questo è un progetto che
prevede due elementi fondamentali una
sonda della NASA chiamata Darth è una
sonda dell'esa chiamata Hera la sonda
della NASA va a colpire una piccola
parte di un asteroide ne parlerò più nel
dettaglio in particolare Il secondario
di un asteroide che si chiama didymos
che si chiama dimorfos e la sonda del
della Sonda dell'esa era va a osservare
questo sistema circa quattro anni dopo
l'impatto per studiare nel dettaglio il
cratere che si è formato e anche
studiare la dinamica di questo sistema
Questa infografica che vedete in questa
immagine vi dimostra esattamente qual è
la Lo scopo della missione d'arte
peraltro devo aggiungere che la missione
d'arta ha concluso le sue fasi
fondamentali circa tre settimane fa
Quindi abbiamo la fortuna di essere
assolutamente immersi in questa realtà
di analisi dati che sta venendo svolta
in questi giorni Allora la missione
d'arte è fatta da due elementi
fondamentali la sonda d'arte che vedete
principale e quel suo piccolo
accompagnatore che si chiama Alice Cube
che tra l'altro è un oggetto che è stato
fornito dall'agenzia Spaziale Italiana
Quindi c'è un piccolo pezzettino di
Italia in questa missione la sonda
d'arte andava ad impattare Il secondario
di questo asteroide binario come vi ho
detto prima quindi un asteroide fatto da
circa da due parti la parte più grande
didymos che è un oggetto da circa 800
metri di diametro e la parte più piccola
dimorfos che è un asteroide da circa 160
metri di diametro di morfous orbita
attorno a didymos
Allora la sonda d'arte colpisce questo
secondario la luna di ditimos E che cosa
fa va a ridurre la a cambiare la
traiettoria di dimorfos in particolare
cambiando il periodo orbitale questo si
dimostra in questa immagine vedete in
bianco l'orbita originale in azzurro
l'orbita modificata dopo l'impatto che
cosa vuol dire modificare l'orbit e
soprattutto Cosa vuol dire osservarlo da
terra Noi dobbiamo capire che sono
oggetti molto lontani molto piccoli e
che quindi la possibilità di osservarlo
è molto difficile che cosa si fa in
questi casi con grandi telescopi da
terra si guarda il corpo e si vede la
quantità di luce che arriva quando la
quantità di luce diminuisce
leggerissimamente vuol dire che dimorfos
sta passando davanti a didymos quindi
vuol dire che in quel momento io posso
prendere il tempo e osservare Qual è la
prossima volta che succederà questa
piccola diminuzione di luce questo mi dà
la misura del periodo orbitale Ecco
l'idea di questa missione a Valle
dell'impatto misurare il periodo
orbitale e quindi vedere esattamente di
quanto è cambiata l'orbita
e le fasi finali di questa missione si
sono svolte Esattamente tre settimane fa
il 27 settembre di quest'anno all'una e
14 ore italiana la sonda d'arte ha
colpito l'asteroide di morphos quelle
che vedete sono un filmato creato da una
sequenza di immagini circa una al
secondo ripresa dalla telecamera
frontale della Sonda d'arte Questa è
andata a usare questa telecamera come se
fosse un mirino con una guida autonoma
che ha colpito a circa 7 chilometri al
secondo questo asteroide vedete le
ultime immagini sono semplicemente
scadenziate e l'ultima che vediamo
Adesso addirittura è incompleta perché
solo una parte di questa è stata
trasmessa e poi la sonda sia andata a
distruggere sull'asteroide e allora ci
chiediamo ma
questo impatto è stato osservato anche a
dire vicino Certamente sì quel piccolo
compagno della Sonda d'arte liscia cui
va ripreso questa immagine in un sorvolo
rischiosissimo che è stato fatto poche
manciate di secondi dopo l'impatto della
scarto sull'asteroide e vedete si è
alzato questo grandissimo pennacchio di
detriti una nube che è stata proprio
ripresa come immagine da queste
telecamere di bordo
contemporaneamente una rete di telescopi
da terra osservava questo impatto e
vedete sulla vostra destra che questa
nube enorme di detriti è stata osservata
con una sequenza di immagini molto
ravvicinate e certamente grandissima
parte di questi detriti è andata persa
nel senso che ha lasciato dal punto di
vista gravitazionale il sistema binario
attenzione perché questo non era così
scontato non era così scontato perché la
massa della Sonda d'arte era di circa
600 kg la massa dell'asteroide che è
stato colpito aveva una dimensione
quindi un peso di circa 10 miliardi di
volte più grande 10 alla 7 per chi ama i
numeri
Allora che cosa vuol dire Potremmo
cercare di paragonare questo evento al
fatto che prendiamo un insetto da 0,1
grammi e lo facciamo impattare contro
un'automobile da 1000 Kg in corsa
Qualcuno potrebbe dire cosa succede
assolutamente nulla Certo però che se
prendete un impatto di 0,1 grammi e non
andate a 7 km al secondo contro un
automobile certamente a quel punto sì
che la sentireste la botta esattamente
quello che è successo in questo caso un
rapporto di 10 alla 7 volte Fra la massa
del proiettile e la massa del
deltasteroide che è stato colpito Questa
rappresenta una prima assoluta è la
prima volta nella storia dell'umanità
che la traiettoria di un corpo celeste è
stato cambiato
vi posso già dire L'analisi dei dati
ancora in corso che il periodo orbitale
di dimorfos rispetto a didymos è stato
cambiato di circa 32 minuti quindi la
traiettoria è cambiata da circa metterci
12 ore a fare un giro e adesso ci mette
circa 11 ore e mezzo e questo è stato
osservato esattamente con questa rete di
telescopi da terra
quale l'obiettivo di Questo esercizio
che qualcuno potrebbe ritenere
abbastanza poco utile l'obiettivo è
quello di dimostrare che se fra qualche
anno un asteroide fosse in rotta di
collisione con la terra Noi saremo in
grado di progettare una sonda sapere
esattamente quanto grande dobbiamo farla
in che traiettoria dobbiamo mandarla per
colpire un oggetto e a quel punto dopo
qualche anno riuscire a fare lievitare
una traiettoria in modo detta tale che
possa passare sufficientemente lontano
dalla terra e questo ovviamente ci
rassicura molto
la domanda che ci facciamo però è questi
fino adesso abbiamo parlato solo del
rischio dovuto agli Asteroidi io però
questa sera voglio portarvi anche a
scoprire un altro aspetto veramente
importante che certamente è altrettanto
poco conosciuto come quello dei rischi
ma sicuramente molto più interessante
pensate per contestualizzare quello che
sto per dire di raggruppare tutto l'oro
del mondo in particolare tutto loro che
è stato già estratto che è stato già
lavorato e che viene tuttora utilizzato
sulla terra e metterlo tutto nello
stesso luogo fisico in particolare Io
l'ho rappresentato in questo luogo
fisico che mi immagino conosciate molto
bene ecco se prendete tutto l'oro del
mondo e lo raggruppate lo mettete in
incubo questo rappresenta un cubo di
circa 22 metri di lato
È pochissimo chissà che cosa ci
immaginavamo noi con la frase tutto loro
del mondo
Allora la domanda che ci poniamo è
quant'è questo oro è circa 200 2000
tonnellate che ovviamente è molto però
ci chiediamo Quant'è la quantità di oro
che ancora rimane da estrarre sulla
terra e circa 50.000 tonnellate Allora
fate il raffronto circa un quarto è
quella che rimane da estrarre rispetto a
quello che è stato già estratto Allora
significa che c'è una forte carenza non
solo di oro ma di altre risorse sulla
terra Allora torniamo e spostiamoci a
questo punto nel cielo torniamo ai
nostri Asteroidi e guardiamo per esempio
a quello che succede per questo
asteroide che prende il nome di 16
psiche è un asteroide metallico che
verrà esplorato dalla NASA nel 2023 con
un lancio che è previsto Appunto nel
2023 con una sonda che si chiama psiche
prende il nome esattamente
dall'asteroide Allora la quantità di oro
che è compresa all'interno di questo
asteroide insieme a tantissimi altri
metalli preziosi e tale per cui se
continuassimo con l'esercizio che
abbiamo fatto prima
cercassimo di metterlo in un cubo
verrebbe un cubo di 8,7 km
Allora voi potete capire benissimo che
noi stiamo sulla terra con un cubo di 22
metri solo in questa asteroide è
compreso una quantità di oro di circa
8,7 km dal punto di vista di un cubo
pieno di oro e se continuiamo con Questo
esercizio un po' di fantasia ma
Permettetemi di farlo e cerchiamo di
valutare Quanto vale tutto questo oro
ovviamente lo facciamo ai prezzi attuali
dell'oro sulla terra Quindi chiaramente
se noi portassimo tutto questo Oro sulla
terra non devo insegnare a voi che il
prezzo scenderebbe terribilmente ma
facciamo finta che questo non succedesse
il valore di tutto questore di circa 700
quintilioni di dollari Cos'è un
quintilione vuol dire mille volte un
quadrilione Che vuol dire mille volte un
trilione Che vuol dire mille volte un
miliardo che mille volte un milione è
una cifra pazzesca inimmaginabile allora
se noi prendessimo tutta questa
ricchezza Ovviamente se potessimo
pensare di averla e la distribuissimo
effettivamente fra tutte le persone
sulla terra ogni singolo individuo sulla
terra avrebbe una ricchezza personale di
circa 100 miliardi di dollari
questi numeri incredibili ci introducono
a un concetto che quello al quale voglio
arrivare di asteroid mining cos'è
l'asteroid mining in italiano potremmo
tradurlo come
esplorazione quindi estrazione di
risorse da asteroidi
Allora può sembrare anche questa un'idea
fantascientifica ma in realtà non lo è e
vi dimostro fra un attimo che ci sono
tantissime realtà che già lavorano in
questo ambito
basti pensare a titolo dei esempio
mostriamo Ancora una volta la nostra
Povera terra con un diametro circa 12
12.800 km e pensiamo che dentro alla
terra esiste una certa quantità di
platino nota in parte la stiamo ancora
estraendo
se paragoniamo questo a quel piccolo
asteroide che vedete sulla vostra destra
ma in realtà capisco benissimo che non
riuscite neanche a vederlo perché
l'asteroide sulla vostra destra ha un
diametro di circa 600 metri Quindi se io
non faccio questo zoom che sto facendo
adesso neanche lo vedete la quantità di
platino contenuto in questa asteroide
metallico che vedete da circa 600 metri
di diametro e circa una volta e mezzo
Quella che c'è sulla terra
ancora andando avanti con i paragoni
Questa è circa 250 volte la intera
catena globale di estrazione annuale del
platino nel mondo quindi questo vi dà
un'idea della ricchezza dal punto di
vista dei materiali di questi oggetti e
ancora per solleticare la vostra
attenzione se ancora non fossi riuscito
a catturarla esistono circa 10.000
Asteroidi di questo tipo nel sistema
solare e circa 1.500 di questi sono più
facilmente raggiungibile dalla Luna dal
punto di vista della energia necessaria
per arrivarci quindi sembra una cosa
assolutamente alla portata
Quali sono le tecnologie critiche per
rendere questa tecnologia o questa idea
dell'asteroid mining molto più
realizzabile La prima è l'esplorazione
quindi noi dobbiamo assolutamente capire
come esplorare catalogare questi oggetti
e questo di solito si fa con piccole
flottiglie di piccoli satelliti che
vanno a operare in modo Cooperativo la
seconda tecnologia importante legata
alle tecniche di aggancio qui vedete una
rappresentazione artistica ma ovviamente
io devo arpionare questi oggetti e
cercare di trasportarli il più vicino
possibile alla terra in modo tale da
poterli lavorare e estrarre le risorse
la terza tecnologia critica critica è
quella legata alle cosiddette
lavorazioni in sito cioè io posso
pensare anche di staccare parti
dell'asteroide come in questa
rappresentazione artistica Vedete un
piccolo astronauta che lavora attorno a
questa roccia e fare una serie di
lavorazioni in modo tale da poi
avvicinare solo alla terra quello che ho
estratto e quindi le risorse estratte da
questi Asteroidi in ultima analisi
l'ultima parte che mi serve è capire
come portare fin sulla terra i nostri
oggetti quindi agganciare parti di
questi Asteroidi e magari con sistemi
molto efficienti per esempio un sistema
di propulsione elettrica come quello
mostrato qui che è alimentato da
pannelli solari allontanare parti
dell'asteroide sufficientemente grandi
da rendere il tutto remunerativo ma non
troppo grandi da rappresentare un
problema dal punto di vista tecnologico
Ecco io sono in conclusione di questa
chiacchierata ma volevo semplicemente
trarre qualche insegnamento gli
Asteroidi sono certamente un grande
rischio ma sicuramente mitigato da parte
di queste missioni che si sono svolte
nelle ultime settimane in particolare
alla missione d'arte che ha mostrato che
è possibile deviare la traiettoria di un
asteroide però devo anche dire che
questo è in parte dovuto dal fatto che
l'umanità negli ultimi dieci anni non si
è comportata come questi due dinosauri
che vedete sulla vostra sinistra che
sembrano un po' due pensionati che
chiacchierano dicendo Ma è proprio
adesso il momento di pensare a qualche
tecnica di difesa planetaria Certamente
per loro era già troppo tardi oppure
come i due innamorati sulla vostra
destra che cercano di esprimere un
desiderio appunto per tornare a quello
che ho detto all'inizio quando vedono
l'asteroide che poi ne comporta
l'estinzione arrivare sulla terra
però e questo è importante gli Asteroidi
sono anche una grandissima opportunità
una sfida tecnologica e ci sono
moltissime realtà anche imprenditoriali
anche in Emilia Romagna e anche a
Bologna che stanno laureando su questi
temi Grazie
[Applauso]